foreign
[Music]
you're doing something
I know that
and he's doing something
it comes from the word he did
you did something past tense
yeah so
Allah means a Juan what
he did well done what does that mean
you are doing
Aloo
homie faluna
they are doing present tense
in this current point in time they are
doing it sometimes Jeff Aluna
it can mean past
tense considering a particular context
yeah we'll go into that for now but
let's just understand it just means more
about it just means present tense verb
happening now
it can also mean
something one does regularly for example
means
regularly meaning
he goes to the Masjid
every day meaning daily does that mean
literally right now he's going to the
Masjid
no it means he does it been to his arm
regularly so it can be expressed
uh Mubarak within the context of him
doing it all the time
no
you're going to see that in the Quran
inshallah so all right let's start with
really easy
foreign
[Music]
shut down
when are you going to
arise from sleep
so is means
he arose from sleep he
arose from sleep so he was once sleeping
now he's awake
yeah write that down we need to know
that meaning if I said
if I said to you
some people say rocket yeah means
you are arising from sleep okay so they
say that again
okay
listen carefully now
I style people
foreign
we have to look at the context
is it a Sweden is it near afternoon or
we don't really know but what we will
say
because sabahan is there
morning it alludes to what
morning who knows what means
in the morning
in proper Arabic
yeah
asila means afternoon
no
so in the Arabic language
ha
means in the morning did I write it no I
didn't
tomorrow morning it means morning yeah
and I feel means after noon
or seal afternoon
[Music]
oh no hate writing English okay
all right Bismillah
what are you doing firstly
[Music]
yes
what are you doing firstly Danny what's
the first thing you're gonna do
is what's the first thing you're going
to do in the morning
he goes on to say uh
okay yeah
[Music]
or brothers wake up
means I wash
then I perform
Ed
well father
hold on let's try that again
is actually here
famous
well done so I washed and I pulled sorry
I perform ablution
and I pray
doing prayer
in the University's mosque then
this is
one but I'll give it to you anyway
formation
things being in its
correct sort of place
means
coming one after another in succession
for now let's work with that meaning
so whenever you see film life I say to
you for example
who came first
then who oh
second uh attachments
who's third
okay so we know the sequence but we
don't know the time span
that's what basically does it shows you
the sequence of how each and every
individual came or when or whatever it
may be
but we do not know the time span so we
say
the structure of how somebody entered or
exited or did what
mataraki
so it has spaced out sort of time period
yeah
all right
where's Tattoo
from West where's the task sorry
oh
yeah this is another word this is a
double verb
no necessarily verb is
used
when you literally wash yourself
I'm washing my body
yeah yeah this is a film about it yeah
it means I'm doing this currently but
this is me saying it in accordance to
the CR
he is asking what you do on a regular
sort of day-to-day basis
would you do that regularly he said he's
explaining his day your Meen
daily how he does his whatever it is
he's doing
so in Arabic if you want to express
you're doing something daily you don't
have to literally mean you're doing it
now you can just use them without it
would you
recite on the day of jummah
does that mean literally on a Monday you
recite in Surah no you're talking about
what you do regularly
that's how Arabic is you're going to
realize that in a bit later inshallah
when you get to other books it can be
used in that context and it's understood
as my phone
now this is just a new verb I don't
think we've taken this before have we we
haven't yeah
there may be a more deeper meaning but
we'll just work with what's known for
now yeah
no no this is something else
this is a difference it's a different
verb this is a very irregular verb yeah
comes from
that sort of not literally coming from
that word but it's yeah don't worry for
now because this is a lot to take on in
terms of words and vocab
try not to question too many things
because I might have to bring you
somewhere else and that might be in book
two
yeah
uh now
yeah but yeah it's like all right so
we'll get to that it does mean letter it
does there's no doubt but what we
actually mean is Adat it's the tool
but don't worry for now just know your
heart for us just know that for now yeah
because this isn't a grammar lesson it's
just a reading slash vocab lesson
when you write this down now you're
black when you go over your notes
yeah I remember we've done the hard for
art
like um has anyone heard of M
yeah
yes that's also hard for art
no no that's another one that means
the same thing but m is slightly
different M bring structure that's also
hard for R yeah t my hands are the
technique that's in book two but this
means nothing right now what does that
mean it means absolutely nothing to you
you will get there and then oh we've
done that
trust me take my word for it yeah
me mentioning it now it relates upon
okay I'm on board when things come to
you newly
Hadith it's like oh what's this Nah if I
tell you now later on you're like yeah
so all right
so I wash and then I perform ablution
then I pray the dawn prayer if he messed
it in Germany in the universities
then
I recite the Quran
coming from the word tilawa
coming from the word brother
feed oversights up
in
terms of what I'm saying here yeah okay
moving on we're almost done
and what are you doing after
what's bada
well done I didn't ask that but since
you're giving it to him
alludes to that witch
comes from time
what did
well done
what are you doing after that
foreign
they go to the university university all
right
well done drools yeah
you may not be doing much but don't
worry
what does ajib mean
s
well done we're complete
response or answer well done
all right you guys ready for this year
these are your questions
so it's upon you guys to respond yeah
and and two will be like
and to come with the correct responses
there is mistakes in the spelling box we
know what it is yeah
with me first then give me the answer
yes I'm
all right
so because you're ready go give us the
answer
yes remember yes
he arises from sleep what time
so you say they sit together yes
so you say yesterday
so he wakes up four o'clock in the
morning sir
people
is
about four o'clock in the morning yeah
no because we're talking about here
we're not talking about you is if I am
addressing a female
I then say it is
when you address her when you're
speaking to her but we're not talking to
her we're saying she does this
yeah here so think of here the word here
yeah the damir the pronoun
go back here and she wakes up early does
that make sense don't worry we'll get to
all this stuff
you know he used to play for everything
you know that
foreign
a difference we're going to get to that
though
it's for mother and also for who
and
it's the same thing but the context is
indicative of what is meant yeah don't
worry he's got it all planned out yeah
he wrote the book not me
it was me it'll be all over the place
don't worry
but this guy knows what he's doing he's
a monster ice
[Music]
all right next one this guy's this is
what does Hashem firstly do
foreign
[Music]
no no don't worry about that you salute
don't worry it's literally in the book
literally
yeah literally in the book you say what
you know all the answers in the book he
doesn't offer anything outside the book
so he's not going to say literally
something which is not there he's on
that's it
and tattoo sunli you are now praying who
are you sadly he is now praying
whom you Saloon
they are praying you know I never forget
he said Simon back in the day yeah I was
asking about the car either the
principal in Islam
basically means who serve as Islam has
been you know
established well done yeah affirmed by
way of your key what's your king
certainty
there's no excommunication of that or
taking out the photo of Islam except by
our certainty here I wanted to know he
said that because I didn't know who made
up this guy because it sounded really
good and it's like a nice principle to
have against you know take food either
whatnot or anyone that makes Tech fit so
I was asking us okay here
who said this yeah he must have bought a
fury
look
[Music]
foreign
but yeah you never forget some of these
instances
with these words so now you know you're
Saloon yeah because I give you a little
story to work with inshallah yeah but
yeah don't forget that's upon Allah he's
a very very
you know continuous sort of check in
regards to teaching books you know
his teachers
weekly them days there any I'm too sure
what he's doing now subhanallah you know
it's a bit difficult he's getting old
but
suddenly but don't worry about that he's
he's not a problem maker
the first problem
second problem him
he's one of them guys that you know uh
if you took him to court yeah he'll end
up digging up crimes that
the judge hasn't found out yet
he's taking you to court for one thing
this guy talks about oh I buried a man
last week
making you crying for this man
he's him that's him
yeah
work with the book
yeah Brothers work with the book yeah
don't bury yourself in new knowledge
which we haven't come across yet
okay
all right Mr Miller okay
all right so let's think how let's think
how we can answer this question
what does he sham do so we say yeah
indeed universities mosque
then
the Quran yet Lou he's reciting
currently yeah
you are a site in the Quran
he
recited past tense
he recited past tense yeah okay don't
worry if you don't notice don't worry
just make sure you understand the word
yet
you say that together
hey now you suddenly
what does that mean
s
who knows this
is
he prays in the universities Masjid
that's actually called in Germany
I believe it is
well I ended it sorry that's another
thing we're going to learn we don't
always have to end it on the last
uh vowel because we end everything on
the Cocoon so you just say
yeah you don't have to say that but if
you want me to say it we can just so we
know but yeah
that's if we carry on the word with
something else now
usually he's got another one
the third one third Criminal
we're talking about one individual
so basically you have another accomplice
of your crime
no no you suddenly he is praying
singular
if you say you saw Lou and you're
talking about more than two people
praying
he is praying currently
yeah so for example
the man into thee
Masjid or you suddenly he's currently
praying yeah
don't worry
we don't know enough yet to know
point out certain things we don't know
enough we'll get there inshallah yeah
you just gotta hang on yeah remember
this lesson is quite advanced
yeah it's Advanced for a reason because
he just wants you to know certain words
it's not asking you about grammar like
for example when you first enter England
and you don't know no English you don't
start questioning people
why is
present and present the same thing when
present is a gift and present amongst
you today
means I'm here in front of you why do
you nobody does this don't have this
attitude of Arabic you know why because
we're still
yeah
don't worry you'll understand it later
yeah don't worry it's not that Akita
like you suck you know diving into
certain things to understand it it's
just it's language in Akita we
understand certain things by way of
details no doubt ask but when it comes
to that Laura just take it for what it
is and then we'll work on it as we you
know develop Insha'Allah yeah
all right now listen carefully
aena
where do you pray look he's talking to
you now look yeah
so he's asking where do you pray
look who are you suddenly he's praying
hey now you suddenly who are you
suddenly he mentioned where does he pray
where does he happen to be praying in
the message
to Sally where do you pray and suddenly
I'm praying in the University
where you pray okay
uh okay let's move on little bit
little bit you know a repeat
from robot who is a robot
ah
I'm so awaken a one
[Laughter]
Robert what does robot mean
to connect to join to tie
Allah says
when it talks about Musa Islam's mother
Allah says had we not had him bound fast
her heart
that she would be of the meaning
you know what my name believe it yes
to basically we brought together a
little bit bring together so
between the two sentences Bay number
between
the two sentences just as it's in the
example let's say this together
foreign
what does that mean
s
i writes basically I carry out my
homework menzil in Arabic means home
yeah menzil
yeah
it means
Menzel
yeah
means house
it can also mean that yeah but let's
just go
yeah it does mean that sir yeah
so you will know if we go court and this
man shows up it's over
just made Bara just free yourself before
him before the judge knows you know him
yeah okay
foreign
what does that mean
there's a mistake there don't worry
about that yeah
okay
so now join between the two sentences
as it's in the previous
uh example were done
as as yeah yeah listen this is a good
example
pray
as he prays
there's also the Hadith Hadith
pray as if you have seen me pray Mr
Hadith Kama means as
yeah
or if we say to somebody
would you want
yeah no leave that one out come out to
eat have you heard of a camera to read
as you want
I know as you wish
as you wish
I want that as you wish yeah
all right this one's a bit of a mumbo
jumbo one let's do this together
all right so f turu
um
yeah
iftar so if I'm not too sure this one's
a bit of a weird one so let's go with F0
after f t rho F2 type F2
it's not written it's not written
are you after yeah I haven't got
anything
oh you've got it written down
alhamdulillah we'll work with what you
wanted yeah
I have
breakfast well done
in a restaurant
of the sentences together
you know let's just read it for what it
is here
um
yeah
so I pray aser then I
you know Assad means in Arabic literally
it means time yeah
exactly by time or if I said to you if
you asked
in our era well Daniel Hassan it can
also mean the era the time period we are
in
so yeah
but developments are many developments
so I read a little then I sleep
read a little
then I sleep anama
or in this case anamu sorry means I am
sleeping yeah but he's talking about
things once again he does on a regular
basis
I would assume here he means before he
like kind of well after he britisher and
whatnot and then he packs up and does
his little wheel and goes to bed yeah
because normally shaytan he sees you
benefit in Reading if it makes you sleep
happens many times
you normally just sleep like you're
reading the benefit at night just fall
asleep it happens
he doesn't want you to benefit from you
know obviously
the book or what's in the book it gives
you about a page or two and then after
that five that you're done Allah
uh it's not all the time some people you
know they read all night masha'allah all
right listen
um
what does that mean
s
then I pray all right moving on to the
next page almost done
so basically extract as it is in the
example
what does that mean
I woke him at one o'clock well done
uh and now he wants you to do that with
fania who reckons they could do that
foreign
do it with five now
I said together
foreign